do you think women want equality yes 100
yes yes 100 yes depends on a woman
okay okay okay okay okay so if that's
true if that's true why aren't there
marches for men to get free drinks and
get into bars for free if we want
equality
i don't know that is though what's that
the ghosts can go in the tub yeah if we
drink why the men come to it yeah
what because we're hot yeah
because are hot and we are not hooked
right but but that's but that's right
but that's not equal we'll talk about
equal pay from like women and men sports
a lot right they always talk about that
and you get there's protests but there's
no protests for the men when they don't
get free stuff
well i think it just like balances it
out you know like they got so much more
only
free drinks
how do how do men get more than women
when women have specific grants for just
being a woman and men don't
how how
how do men get more than women when
women have specific grants for just
being a woman woman and men
don't can i just say one thing